nouveau parlement nouveau gouvernement
nouvelle dynamique la principale raison
pour laquelle la chambre sièges avant
les fêtes faire adopter la promesse
phare des libéraux nous aiderons
davantage ceux qui en ont besoin
donnant moins à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
besoin
c'est le principe à la base de la
réduction d'impôt aps la classe moyenne
l'opposition n'a pas mis tant ils
trouvaient des femmes
malheureusement les canadiens se
réveille aujourd'hui avec la réalité ça
ne tiendra pas ses promesses sont
irréalisables et réalisons la personne
gagnant un revenu médian ne soit rien
par contre ceux et celles gagnant entre
80 et 200 mille dollars recevront le
maximum de la réduction d'impôt malgré
une critique le ministre des finances
maintient le cap en donnant le coup
d'envoi au programme pour qu'il entre en
vigueur dès le 1er janvier le taux
d'imposition de 22% sera réduit à 20 25
% environ 9 millions de canadiens auront
droit à cette baisse d'impôts à chaque
année mais combien coûtera cette mesure
contrairement à ce que les libéraux
avaient promis le nouveau taux
d'imposition de 33% aux mieux nantis ne
pourra compenser les pertes de revenus
qu'entraînera la baisse des impôts de la
classe moyenne
le ministre des finances et force est de
l'admettre
ça va coûter un peu plus pour le
gouvernement un manque à gagner d'un
milliard deux cents millions de dollars
pour une mesure qui devait
s'autofinancer et coincé mais la
meilleure stratégie à adopter
c'est toujours la même c'est c'est
d'être transparent est d'admettre que
les revenus ne seront peut-être pas au
rendez vous le gouvernement a dû refaire
ses calculs les comptables sont très
très ingénieux et on arrive toujours à
trouver un échappatoire quelconque et là
c'est pas tout le monde entier qui
s'engagent dans la grosse planification
fiscale mais se chicanait quelques
heures pour que le coût soit et nous
devons les perspectives économiques qui
s'assombrissent
le gouvernement at il les moyens de ses
ambitions le ministre des finances fait
le pari que les allégements fiscaux
seront réinvestis dans l'économie une
mesure marque qui coûte donc plus cher
que prévu en plus une économie qui va
pas très bien
le ministre des finances bill mais on
nous doit donc être extrêmement prudent
vendredi avec le discours du trône
celedon disait que c'était le temps de
passer à l'action mais aujourd'hui là on
a vu les libéraux être confrontés à la
réalité du pouvoir
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que
les ministres n'ose plus parler d'un
déficit de moins de 10 milliards tel que
promis en campagne électorale
l'économie ne tourne pas à plein régime
les finances publiques sont dans un
moins bon état que prévu alors belmore
nojoud prudence il abaisse ses attentes
alors c'est pour cent dans le fond que
la promesse d'un dif c'est deux de moins
de 10 milliards mais plus sur la liste
de ses objectifs et là ce sont les mois
les plus importants qui s'en viennent
pour le ministre qui doit commencer ces
jours-ci à préparer son premier budget
c'est une question de crédibilité
c'est dans cet esprit que les libéraux
nuances de plus en plus leurs discours
économique
évidemment tout ça fait monter la
pression en ce moment parce que le
gouvernement doit réussir à faire la
preuve que son plan en infrastructure
peut nourrir la croissance au canada
oui alors on verra la suite merci marc
roy et ces mesures elles ont un impact
concret sur le budget des familles
bonsoir en vrai a annoncé les hnwi et
dans certains cas ça va représenter des
milliers de dollars de plus dans leurs
poches absolument le ministère des
finances calcul que bon pour les
célibataires et certaines familles en
moyenne ce seront quelques centaines de
dollars par contre pour les familles la
classe moyenne qui ont vraiment été
ciblés par les mesures mises de l'avant
par le gouvernement libéral ça peut
effectivement représenter plusieurs
milliers de dollars pour les économies
d'impôts grâce à l'abaissement du taux
marginal d'imposition mais surtout grâce
aux prestations pour enfants qui seront
bonifiées vol oui vous avez l'exemple
avec un couple avec deux enfants des
revenus de 50 mille dollars les
économies d'impôts les impôts en moins à
payer c'est environ 750 dollars les
prestations pour enfants supplémentaires
3830 dollar gain total donc à peu près
quatre mille cinq cents ça représente
une variation nos gonds
tentation du revenu disponible de 9,2
pour cent autre exemple un même couple
avec deux enfants revenus de 100 mille
dollars cette fois les économies
d'impôts similaires c'est la prestation
pour enfants à ce moment là qui est
moins généreuse plus on a des revenus
élevés un gain total tout de même de
près ce que 2800 $ variations du revenu
disponible de 3 6% est effectivement
plus on a d'argent dans les poches des
familles de la classe moyenne
condé pas et qu on stimule l'économie
exactement et on l'a on verra ce que ça
va donner vraiment il ya aussi eu des
changements annoncés sur le celi il
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt oui
effectivement le plafond du celi de
cotisation était avait été en fait
majoré à 10000 dollars sous les
conservateurs ce sera ramené à 5500 $ à
partir du 1er janvier mais sans rien
n'est pas limité pour les contribuables
puisqu'il était assez peu nombreux à
cotiser le maximum merci beaucoup
on réalise un prêt à revoir